is there a way
to invent primes to generate primes and
never ever ever
come up with a problem and the answer is
yes there is
so long as you know what this number is
okay
these are called
these are called mills
okay
so mills was a mathematician
and he said look
there's a special number actually there
should be more than one special number
but this is the smallest one that's
known okay such that if you do a
particular thing to it
you will always get every single time
not like mercen right every time you'll
get a prime now i'll show you the
formula but things need to be explained
about it okay so this is what the
formula looks like um
i know it looks weird i'll explain it
okay so what's this
first okay you've got these um weird
boxes out here and it looks a bit like a
matrix but i left off the tops which is
important okay this is called the floor
function yep that's the actual name the
floor function
what it tells you is
it rounds down
whatever you give it to the nearest
integer below okay so we're familiar
with the fact that you know 3.1 rounds
down 3.2 rounds down
etc etc 3.5 rounds up
the floor function rounds down no matter
what the decimal is so 3.5
floor function would equal 3.
3.9 don't care floor function
another way of thinking about it is it
subtracts the non-integer part whatever
that might be always subtract
uh there is by the way your opposite
function to this it's not called the
floor function what do you think it's
called the root function
come on we're inside people it's the
ceiling function
the ceiling function and it does the
opposite it does the opposite look 3.1
we would usually round that down but the
ceiling function would make it round two
or four okay so anyway the ceiling
function happens to not be very useful
in this particular contact so what's
this the floor function of this number
what's this number
um this is the greek letter
mu
mu right
and it's m for mils right so
rather than using m which usually means
mass in maths but anyway
so
mu is a mill's number this is the
smallest one that's known mills
theorized that there were more such
numbers okay
if you raise
mu
okay to the power of 3 to the power of n
where ends any number you like
you'll always get you'll always get a
prime number every single time
okay
now keep in mind this is the number okay
so what i would advise you to do is get
your calculator out manually punch this
number in
okay
and then store it in your so you don't
have to type it out again okay store it
as a letter right like say store and
then pick c d whatever you like them you
can pick m if you like okay so if you
cannot remember how to do that
here's the way you can do it
okay
so what you want to do is first step
just type the number first step is type
the number so 1.2306
okay
now once you've got that number there
press equals
that number will go on the bottom
display not just your working and then
what you want is shift
this button which says rcl for recall
just above it in yellow it says sto for
store so you go shift store and then
pick one of the uh on my calculator the
letters are all in like magenta pink
dark pink sort of color and pick a
letter okay and then it'll tell you yeah
all right that answer is now in
whichever letter you've chosen
okay got it
so that's just for convenience just so
you can manipulate it
all right now
what are the numbers what are the primes
that get generated by this thing well
you're going to take this number and
you're going to raise it
to the power of 3 to the power of some
number so if i say n equals one n equals
one
i'm going to raise mu to the power of
three to the power of one so that's mu
cubed
okay mu cubed does that make sense okay
so you go through and i've got it on um
a right so you go alpha
the button with a and then you cube it
so what do you get well before i round
it i go 2.22949
right but of course i want the floor
function of that right the floor
function so you go floor
floor so that of course is equal to two
which is
prime oh cool
all right hold on need partition but
that's just one number okay let's do the
next one right so you go mu to the power
of now if i say
m equals
2
right then this will be mu to the power
3 squared which of course is 9.
okay
so you punch it in right you go
mu to the power of 11.
oh sorry nine be your pardon
and then the number that you get is
11.082 etc but of course you want the
floor
which is 11 which is prime
does that mean that according to the new
function one is a prime number uh well
okay so for
four natural numbers
okay so positive like
no actually sorry yeah so not non-zero
not counting zero is that okay
so i started from n equals one
of them
well we went from two to eleven
so i've skipped
three five and seven but then again
every prime generator every prime
generator will skip some numbers so you
just you know and for to be honest i
don't mind all that much for the my
intents because remember for
cryptography i don't care about these
small prime numbers anyway they're no
use i want big ones okay they're the
ones that are really valuable for
encryption okay
now just because our calculators can
handle it what's the next meals prime
it would be mu to the power of
27. now can you see by the way why i
gave you this ridiculous number of
decimal places right i'm raising it to
the 27th power these numbers down here
are small right now but you multiply
them by themselves 27 times
and it will matter
i think my calculator at least it can go
up to the next one which is
81 i think so it'll do mu to the power
of 81.
no it's not i get two five two one zero
zero eight eight seven